hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and for me one of
the funniest shows that's most densely
packed with miserable jokes is Silicon
Valley on HBO whether or not you even
watch it which you should if you don't
each seasons 10 second opening credits
sequence is updated with subtle jabs at
the tech industry now we here at new
rock stars have made it our mission to
break down your favorite movies the TV
shows for nerdy references and inside
jokes that you might have missed the
first time around because you know you
just enjoy shows like normal people
whereas I stare at the screen like a cat
watching a clip with birds in it now
that Silicon Valley season 5 is
premiered I thought we'd unpacked the
new opening credits sequence for all the
little changes and the deeper meaning
behind them because you know you can't
just laugh at jokes guys you have to
really get them okay let's start with
this Amazon Prime air drone zips past
the camera this was added back in season
four - not at Amazon's use of drones to
deliver stuff before delivered a slice
of pizza now it carries a wholefoods box
because you know Amazon bought out the
Whole Foods grocery chain soon they will
own all of us the Google campus remains
along with its parent company alphabet
along with the logos for LinkedIn reddit
and PayPal over on the far side there
those were all added in season 4 along
with Tesla's headquarters but now if you
look closely throughout the streets you
can see a fleet of Tesla trucks probably
delivering electric cars and solar
powered products reflecting their recent
growing sales on the bottom right
returning our eBay and nest you know
nest is a smart home thermostat and
security camera company is a live stream
app twitch mobile game companies Zynga
storage a Dropbox with a little file
swooping into it and Yelp with its
5-star rating both are on the building
with the energy pot dome that's been
there since season 1 there are nap pods
or chairs with the dome covers that help
people relax and snooze but the big
change here is uber and lyft last season
they were inflating balloons that bumped
against each other reflecting the
rivalry between the rideshare apps
they're also used to be a balloon for DD
Xiaojing a Chinese version of uber
floating away from them now the DD
balloon is gone and uber and lyft have
expanded in their own buildings and if
you look closely at the roofs of those
buildings you can see people leaving
uber across the bridge to lift
reflecting the drivers and customers who
are fleeing uber due to the bad press
it's gotten also I love this cash is
pouring out of burrs building suggesting
that the company is hemorrhaging money
now last season those buildings were
occupied by sea
lack that's the super popular
cloud-based organization software we use
it here and Farrah knows the healthcare
startup that was investigated for fraud
it actually used to be a little FBI
trucks out front now fairness is gone
completely
the uber building still does have the
season two editions of billboards for
Appcelerator the software that measures
app performance and 23andme that's the
creepy genetic test company that's
probably cloning you somewhere meanwhile
notice how the Twitter sign has grown
significantly compared to last season
which previously had golden parachutes
for Twitter executives taking off and
getting huge severance packages now it's
ladder has been removed in Twitter looms
large probably reflecting the company's
turnaround specifically how political
news has shifted onto it and made it
essential once more another new addition
behind the lyft building is a golden
tower for a coin base one of the many
crypto currencies it's in the shape of a
stack of coins at the base of it
construction equipment excavates more
digital currencies that swoop over and
stack up silver ones for a light coin
and a gold one featuring the etherium
logo now behind these is apple's campus
which has finally been completed
previous seasons have just shown a
gradually under construction now let's
slide on over to the left side beside
ebay is the returning intel building
with the sign for kind financial that's
a financial tech firm for the cannabis
industry along with this season one
building with the Netscape logo being
replaced by Google Chrome beside it is a
logo for Android Google's mobile OS
across the street from it is Google's
YouTube building with a ping-pong table
on the roof and somewhere inside of it
somewhere and behind Android is the
season 4 edition of Airbnb with its logo
atop a tiny hotel but behind that is the
campus of Facebook which contains
probably the biggest new joke of this
season 5 sequence you look closely the
Facebook logo briefly switches into
Russian letters a reference of course to
Russia using Facebook to interfere with
the 2016 US election now even though
these are Cyrillic characters this isn't
the actual translation for Facebook in
Russian it is really just spell out
nonsense that looks like the word
Facebook the Pinterest logo remains
behind Facebook's campus but the
Facebook logo no longer overshadows
whatsapp in oculus now that they are
Facebook subsidiaries they merely
loyally sit beside it on its campus you
can see the whatsapp phone logo in the
oculus VR headset also if you look
closely there's the snapchat ghost logo
last season it flowed
beside Facebook's campus now it floats
away perhaps reflecting snapchat kind of
fading into obscurity
ever since Kylie Jenner's tweet costed
Toulouse 1.3 billion dollars
another change from last season a juice
arrow building was added but then it
immediately falls apart I joke about
juice arrows suspending operations last
September meanwhile across this whole
city block whereas the streets in season
four were filled with Soylent trucks
they've now scaled down to just the one
truck over on Facebook's campus near
that big like icon the pork John's are
still there though talk about the issues
some people's digestion sad with the
stuff the remaining logos surrounding
the main Silicon Valley title remain
unchanged Google's blogger platform
hewlett-packard hooli that's the
fictional Google / Apple type company in
the show or a col with its rooftop
rock-climbing wall for its CEOs a love
of rock climbing
Samsung added in season four with its
rooftop bungee jumpers it was a nod at
the company's VR stunts where they
suspended users and bungee cables and if
you're looking more closely you can
barely make out people unicycling on the
roof maybe that's a reference to the Uni
wheel X r3 which Tuesday's Samsung
lithium battery or maybe just to the
general unicycling hippie culture of
Silicon Valley meanwhile the building
beside Oracle previously featured
science for Yahoo and Alibaba Alibaba
growing larger and larger over Yahoo
over the seasons to reflect Yahoo's
decline in brand strength now both Yahoo
and Alibaba
signs are gone meanwhile beside this
building on the street they kept the
joke with the purple Yahoo bus carrying
the multi-million dollar home this is a
joke about the rising housing prices in
Silicon Valley due to all these rich
tech companies taking over the area in
2014 pissed off Valley locals blocked a
yahoo bus and threw up on it you can
actually see one of these protesters
doing that here and speaking of
protesters I caught one other tiny
detail that was updated down at
YouTube's building in previous seasons a
small group of protesters - signs
marched in front of YouTube now the
protesters start this season 5 sequence
at uber and then they scramble across
the street to YouTube and then they move
on now I'm not entirely sure what this
means my guess is that it refers to the
general outrage machine like how uber
was under a lot of heat for its various
scandals and then the angry online mob
moved over to get pissed off at YouTube
for all the controversy among the more
popular youtubers in the past year and
now this crowd is moving on somewhere
else I'm in the general direction of
Facebook actually and you know what it
deserves it
those are all the details that I spot
but here's my question for you guys what
other app would you like to see made fun
of in these credits Instagram Netflix
personally I'd love to see a bunch of
pirate ways popping up as they get
swatted down like whack-a-mole comment
down below or tweet me directly I da vas
and following rockstars on Twitter for
updates on our videos please like this
video share it around subscribed into
rockstars for these kinds of deep dives
and all the stuff that you love Game of
Thrones Rick and Morty Westworld
everything Star Wars and Marvel - thanks
for watching guys bye